[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans point de vue ravi
de vous retrouver n'oubliez pas poster
vos questions vos commentaires on les
attend voici les sujets qu'on a retenue
dans l'actualité d'abord les retraites
la réforme et lancez vous le savez mais
est ce vraiment la bonne c'est toute la
question
on sait que le sujet vous intéresse nous
parlerons aussi de la burqa c'est l'onu
qui remet le sujet sur le tapis l'onu
avec son très militant comité des droits
de l'homme qui s'apprête à épingler la
france pour sa loi d'interdiction de la
burqa
nous reviendrons aussi sur cette longue
séquence du remaniement et surtout sur
cette petite phrase prononcée hier par
edouard philippe pas une feuille de
papier à cigarette entre lui et emmanuel
macron alors doit-on le croire on vous
pose la question enfin les ravages de
l'alcool dénoncée par les médecins ils
signent une lettre ouverte demandant une
plus forte taxation de l'alcool mais la
ministre de la santé agnès buzyn n'est
sans doute pas totalement libre en la
matière pour en parler bonjour caroline
valentin merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
vous êtes essayer ces éditorialistes
notamment dans le magazine col causeur
et au figaro vox également vous êtes
aussi le co auteur de une france soumise
les voies du refus c'est paru chez albin
michel en 2017 et ça a été dirigée par
georges bensoussan
merci ferghana ziri d'être avec nous
vous êtes prêt e journaliste analyste en
politiques publiques et vous collaborez
à plusieurs sites dont l'institut des
recherches économiques et fiscales
bonjour georgia kuzmanovic m aux jo si
nous avoir rejoint les habitudes point
de vue vous connaissent bien
vous êtes porte parole sur les questions
internationales et de défense de jean
luc mélenchon et la france a soumises en
général et bonjour aux arcs landrais
vous êtes rédacteur en chef du service
économie france du figaro et on ne vous
présente plus non plus aux habitudes
point de vue je crois alors on va parler
des retraites marque avec vous et avec
vous tous on n'en sait donc un peu plus
sur le futur système universel de
retraite celui voulu par emmanuel macron
celui que jean paul delevoye
le haut commissaire à la réforme vient
de dévoiler alors fini en principe les
régimes spéciaux les disparités très
fortes entre salariés et indépendants
mais ce nouveau système est il à la
hauteur des enjeux
est-il aussi à la hauteur des
changements dans le
du travail oui répond évidemment le
commissaire chargé de la réforme jean
paul delevoye qui était ce matin sur
france inter
il n'est pas du tout adapté au 21ème
siècle
personne ne peut dire que les
professions ne vont pas évoluer on me
dit que dans les facs les étudiants en
médecine disent on veut être plus
salariés que médecin c'est la fin du
système de retraite des médecins
libéraux
si la solidarité est enfermé dans les
professions demain le moindre aléa
ce sera un conflit entre paul et les
professions ah non je veux pas qu'on
touche fonctionnaires à je ne veux pas
qu'on touche aux journalistes je ne veux
pas il faut embarquer aujourd'hui la
totalité de la société française et de
renforcer la cohésion
intragénérationnelle marque
globalement ce projet oui mais pas dans
le bon sens encore trop timide
synthétique que possible aussi ça te dit
que moi aussi j'ai un dicton que je dis
souvent c'est à la fin de la foire qu'on
compte le nombre de blues je pense qu'il
est beaucoup trop tôt aujourd'hui pour
être capable de juger de la finalité de
cette réforme qui sur le papier est
effectivement une réforme d'envergure
systémiques auxquels on n'a jamais pensé
ni même commencé à toucher
grosso modo depuis
la mise en oeuvre de la section 45 donc
sur le papier c'est une révolution les
changements à venir sont majeurs mais
après tout est dans le détail et tout
est dans la maille en deux ça va être
mis en oeuvre je prends juste un exemple
nicolas sarkozy quand il a été élu
président la public en 2007 a dit moi je
vais faire en moins de six mois ce que
jacques chirac n'a pas fait en 12 ans
c'est à dire je vais réformer les
régimes spéciaux de retraite je vais les
supprimer c'est d'accès c'est glandeur
de cheminots là moi je vais les mettre
au pas et je vais leur mettre une durée
de cotisation et un temps de 1 h départ
à traite comme une autre c'est
effectivement ce qu'il a fait hier qu'il
a collé sur le papier des mêmes droits
de départ à la retraite pour les
cheminots par exemple les gens de la
sncf que pour et tout l'ensemble des
régimes spéciaux que pour les cadres du
privé de la force publique
sauf qu'après il a renvoyé à la
négociation par entreprise les contrôles
et l'application non pas l'application
des compensations et au final vous avez
une réforme qui sur le papier se tient
et quand vous intégrez les compensations
qui in fine et coûte plus cher que celle
qu'elle a voulu enlever à la base
donc tout ça pour vous dire quoi oui sur
la théorie et la pratique y avoir il va
se passer déjà renom et qu' il y aura
entre temps des élections il va se
passer des confrontations avec les
organisations syndicales et patronales
et que la copie finale sera probablement
un peu différente voire beaucoup de
l'esprit de la copie initiale
alors merci déjà pour cette analyse très
synthétique je vous donne la parole aux
uns et aux autres notamment à vous tous
genres jake hoffman oui je voudrais
d'abord qu'on écoute alexis corbière
député la france a soumises de cette
année qui était ce matin sur europe 1
réfléchissez à ce que je vous ai dit sur
les retraites qui vous font les poches
danger ce système de points et dangereux
ils vont vous baissez votre tête
vivons vous encourager à vous endetter
auprès d'organismes privés pour avoir
une retraite compléter et ça c'est pas
bon c'est pas la république telles que
moi je la veux c'est pas un peu court
comme argumentation
non c'est pas court comme argumentation
en plus d'abord il va ces cours dit
comme ça mais après on peut l'expliquer
donc il a déjà commencé avec la csg
certain nombre de familles qui qui dans
le nord de la france par exemple qui
vivent sur la retraite
deux personnes qui ont été ouvrier ou
kit employés pendant des années et les
amputés de 20 euros ça peut sembler
quelqu'un qui qui a énormément d'argent
comme monsieur mâcon en rien du tout
mais pour certaines familles c'est une
catastrophe quand vous avez cinq six
sept personnes qui survivent dessus mais
c'est un poison de dingue comme le
dirait évidemment il n'y pense pas mais
c'est mais c'est déjà prendre dans les
poches et après effectivement macron
applique les directives l'union
européenne dans tous les domaines y
compris celui de retraite et il s'agit
de casser la cohésion ce national
il s'agit de casser un système qui était
mis en place dorée distribution
nationale je vous interromps parce que
il ya un sondage afin c'est une étude
qui a été faite par la fondation pour
l'innovation politique dont le parisien
fait état ce matin plus de sept français
sur dix ne sont pas satisfaits du
système actuel mais système actuel est
sabordé petit à petit depuis trente ans
on peut pas casser un système qui a été
mis en place après après la deuxième
guerre mondiale par le conseil national
de la résistance
penser dans le partage entre français
mais maintenant ces macro mais le coup
d'accélérateur et donc on est on est en
train de passer d'un système où on
coopère entre les générations où on fait
rire mais c'est un système à
l'américaine où on est obligé tellement
sait où on va être obligés de cotiser
mais c'est pour ça que le public
je dirais que c'est pour ça que depuis
que sarkozy est président son frère
amédée médéric malakoff propose une des
compléments oui mais à les proposer en
fait parce que le dg de malakoff médéric
mais vu que je suis
on a compté mais il ya eu pendant 20 30
ans une hausse de la productivité une
amélioration de revenus du capital
par contre il ya une baisse des revenus
des salariés et des retraités il est
temps que ça change
il faut que les bénéfices des hausses de
productivité soit réparti par tous et y
compris pour les retraités écoutez moi
je ne vois pas ce que vous reprochez à
cette réforme elle est lé jacobine elle
s'inscrit exactement dans votre
paradigme on ne rompt pas avec la
logique de la répartition me semble-t-il
on ne fait que généraliser un système
qui aujourd'hui alors certes a ses
défauts est complètement déséquilibrée
sur le film sur le plan financier parce
qu'on sait très bien que sur le plan
démographique
le système de retraite tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui conçu n'est pas soutenable
toujours falloir un moment ajuster les
pensions augmenter les cotisations ou
faire reculer le des plages de départ à
la retraite
donc on est ici dans un paradigme tout à
fait centralisateur et moi j'ai
l'impression que monsieur corbières il
le contestait juste pour contester parce
que voilà il est dans son rôle mais la
réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui cette
réforme ne va pas du tout dans la bonne
direction on sait qui des allemands
aujourd'hui la seule manière de sauver
le système de retraite et si un sujet
sur lequel dit rêve travail par
intervient de mon collègue laurent papy
qui va sortir un rapport dans quelques
jours l'enjeu aujourd'hui effectivement
c'est de mettre fin à ce pillage
intergénérationnel qui n'est pas
soutenable sur le plan démographique
aujourd'hui on a trois cotisants pour de
retraités je crois et n'est simplement
pas soutenable la seule solution pour
sortir par le haut c'est d'introduire
progressivement un système par
capitalisation
tout le monde le sait ça et ce n'est pas
ce d'accord on se dirige donc vous
auriez de comptes en voudriez applaudir
cette réforme
ça va généraliser le système tout à fait
un parfait mais dans le même paradigme
dans lequel on se situe aujourd'hui et
c'est finalement par une valentin pour
le moment elle est plutôt bien accueilli
cette réforme avec toutes les réserves
d'usagé par les partenaires sociaux
comme on vit aussi bien medef que
syndicat avec encore beaucoup de bémols
mais il n'y a pas de levée de boucliers
c'est surprenant ce qu'on avait dit la
réforme des retraites l'aca pas
forcément ça va c'était un tollé je
crois qu'en fait elle est bien
accueillie où elle épate encore
accueilli parce qu'on n'a pas encore
fait les les prévisions de retraite de
rezé quand on dit les projeter trop
tendre c'est beaucoup trop tôt après il
faut quand même se rappeler de ce
qu'avait dit françois fillon
ce n'était pas forcément mon candidat
mais parce que le président macron avait
annoncé ce système de réforme de
retraite dès la présidentielle et savait
était donc discuter un des rares points
politiques et l'avait été il avait dit
ils avaient prévenu que c'est un
problème qu'il faut se méfier parce que
le point les valeurs du point évoluera
en fonction de données conjoncturelles
et structurelles
voilà aujourd'hui alors moi j'ai pas les
chiffres que vous avez moi j'ai eu
j'avais 4,64 sept travailleurs pour un
retraité en 60 4,6 et 4,8 65 aujourd'hui
tant qu 1,65 travailleurs pour un
retraité 4,35 demain donc on voit en
fait que plus ça va aller moins d'argent
pour financer les retraites
hélas ce point là n'est pas du tout
abordé par deux le voit les premiers
commentaires sur lors de notre
internaute dont le surnomme le
commentaire il semble évident que
supprimer les quarante deux régimes de
retraite soit une bonne proposition
alors ça c'est vrai que dans le dans le
l'affichage c'est vrai que c'est quelque
chose qui marque on dit il ya quarante
deux régimes spéciaux on va vérifier
tout ça au régime 42 régime
alors d'abord on va pas vers la
suppression on va vers un gie un régime
universel qui dit que 1 euro cotisé
donnera les mêmes droits à tout le monde
donc à florent vérité c'est pas une
suppression des 42 régime c'est une
harmonisation de droit puisque des
régimes ils ont résisté
il en restera on ne sait pas par exemple
salle jean paul ii loi ne le dis pas
parce que la concertation n'est pas allé
dans ce sens là est ce qu'on aura un
régime par points uniques pour
l'équivalent aujourd'hui de du régime de
base pour les deux privés les régimes
complémentaires ou est ce qu'on aura
on va créer un régime complémentaire
dans le public il n'existe pas
aujourd'hui rien que ça si on maintient
cette dualité entre base et
complémentaires ça fait deux régimes est
pas un
et d'ailleurs je pense que la confusion
peut venir du fait que les dans l'esprit
des gens universelle veut dire unique or
on a pas on ne va pas avoir un régime
unique vous allez avoir les cheminots
qui garderont un nombre de prérogatives
aux mains sales nombre de particularités
mais ça sera à l'entreprise elle-même de
le financer
soit en augmentant les tarifs soit en
faisant des économies peu importe mais
en tout cas il y aura un socle de base
qui sera un euro cotisé qui donnera le
même droit pour tout le monde et s'il
doit y avoir des différences ensuite en
fonction des statuts en fonction des
types de salariat en fonction des usages
en fonction de la de la souffrance au
travail en fonction de la pénibilité des
carrières ça sera aux organisations
voire aux branches de les financer et le
même c'est la nuance et la fonctionnaire
ça paraît aujourd'hui vous savez les
fonctionnements cette différence
or aujourd'hui il ya une petite phrase
qui est passée totalement inaperçue le
financement il ya une phrase qui est
passé totalement inaperçu dans le dans
le relevé de conclusions de jean paul
delevoye hier c'est à dire que les
totaux à l'employeur de ventre est
identique dans le public et dans le
privé il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui par
exemple dans le public enfin dans le
privé par dont le taux employeurs ses
28% dire que l'un las la masse des
cotisations pour financer les retraites
c'est 28 % dans le public autant
employeur c'est 75%
donc ça veut dire que si on va vers une
harmonisation soit on augmente au privé
alors il ya une loi qui fixe à 28 pour
cent le plafond peut pas aller au delà
soit en descend le taux dans la fonction
publique ça veut dire que finalement il
y aura un de financement qui sera moins
alors là il ya une manif manière d une
manière de dieu qui est très technique
de films de file de la chose c'est
plutôt que de financer sa part
une subvention de l'état en financera 10
actuellement part de l'impôt alors c'est
doc est payant mais ces derniers
aujourd'hui ça serait de demain mais
pour des raisons aussi démographique on
continuera à financer des régimes
spéciaux non puisque la fonction
publique aujourd'hui dans la grande
majorité des cas hormis ce qu'on appelle
les catégories actives et qui sont bien
légitimes ces défilés militaires les
policiers les pompiers qui ont le droit
de partir en retraite avant parce qu'ils
ont eu des métiers très difficile et
très compliqué la fonctionnaire de
fonctionnaires classique il à droite par
guide nous faut qu'ils partent à 62 ans
avec 42 ans de cotisation s'il veut
partir avant il a une forte décote c'est
son droit c'est le mode de calcul
aujourd'hui qui est différent le mode de
calcul de son niveau de pensions pas les
conditions de son départ si elles sont
identiques alors vous parlez des cotes
ya un sujet qui fait déjà débat aussi
cette histoire d'âge qui vont avec
finalement on dit mais est-ce que c'est
pas une forme de recul de l'âge de
départ à la retraite déguisé george's ça
vous inspire ça est ce que oui mais le
problème est global
on n'arrête pas d'augmenter le départ de
l'âge à la retraite dans un pays qui
compte 6 millions de chômeurs ce qui est
en soi d'une logique hein
implacable est ce qu'on ne veut pas
c'est la redistribution de la richesse
créée mais les travaux de piketty y ont
même été étudiés par barack obama qui
nous ne sommes pas être humble celik à
la maison blanche qui montre clairement
que sur les 30 dernières années
10.122 du travail sont allés au capital
de multiples manières en payant moins de
retraite en payant moins les salaires en
prenant plus de taxes ici que sur que
sur les plus riches qui d'ailleurs eu en
plusieurs milliers de niches fiscales
mais bon c'est du vent ça pose moins de
problème est bien là il faut revenir en
arrière il faut redistribuer la richesse
parce que l'argent corrompt les
retraités ce sera des gens qui
consommeront dans notre pays et qui
feront le carnet de commandes on peut
continuer à vouloir réduire à salaire
réduit la retraite forcer les gens à
travailler plus pour moins d'argent
on ira encore plus rapidement vers le
gouffre économique dans laquelle
d'ailleurs visiblement on se dirige a
déjà à très grands pas marc une autre
question vous répondez à dire juste sur
ce point mais est-ce que aussi le
s'étaient soulevés dans le figaro ce
matin il ya un point qui quand même un
peu que risque de faire tiquer c'est
cette histoire de minimum vieillesse qui
finalement se rapproche maintenant des
petites retraites à quelques dizaines
d'euros près 50 euros près vrai cessez
le c'est tout le charme et et la
contradiction de la logique macro nian
qui veut avant tout libérer le travail
et que le travail paye c'est pour ça que
d'ailleurs il à l'augmentation de la csg
est compensée par une baisse de
cotisations pour les salariés et
compensent également pour pourrait bien
obliger à un autre mécanisme pour les
indépendants mais qui ne l'est pas pour
les retraités
et donc on s'est rendu compte on se rend
compte effectivement que la promesse
macro nien d'augmenter de 100 euros les
millions us pour les porter à près de
900 euros
in fine et à la fin du fin il y aura
qu'un décalage de 100 à 150 euros avec
les plus piratés donc ça veut dire quoi
c'est à dire que quelqu'un qui n'a pas
travaillé tout au long de sa vie pour
quelques raisons que ce soit qu'elles
soient bonnes ou mauvaises c'est pas du
tout un jugement de valeur
quelqu'un qui n'a pas travaillé
bénéficiera automatiquement de 900 euros
soit un montant de vieillesse qui sera
inférieure de 100 euros à quelqu'un qui
a trimé toute sa vie qui a été ici
commerçants l' artisan la agriculteurs
qui s'est levée tôt le matin quand on en
a bavé qu'à payer des cotisations pour
in fine et se retrouver avec quoi avec
une retraite à peine supérieure à celle
de quelqu'un qui n'a pas travaillé
c'est assez comment dire un tweet 28
intellectuellement surprenant dans quand
on remet dans cette danse et adn macro
niang qui dit que le travail doit payer
est difficile français libéré le travail
c'est bien réduire les salaires ça non
non libéré le travail c'est faire en
sorte que les gens ne travaillent plus
ils soient de travail soit parce que non
non ça c'est l'inversé la version bossa
nova vida travail il faut traduire ça
veut dire réduire les salaires et
augmenter le temps de travail avec le
même salaire ce qui paraît alors ce qui
revient beaucoup parmi les internautes
c'est cette remarque de toujours notre
intérêt le commentaire de toute manière
le système actuel n'est plus viable
finalement est ce que ce n'est pas sale
constat on en reviens petit peu à la
question centrale c'est il faut bien
trouver une solution évidemment que
c'est bien ça la question est
aujourd'hui quand vous regardez en
juillet mais les lire réformes menées
ces dernières décennies on est toujours
dans les ajustements techniques des
paramètres quel groupe on va pénaliser
quel groupe on va favoriser quelle
génération
vers quelle génération va t'on re
distribués en fonction des enjeux
électoraux donc on n'est pas du tout
dans dans dans une gouvernance
d'ensemble on est vraiment dans 10 dans
des ajustements purement électoralistes
et le véritable sujet en effet c'est le
paradis le système de retraite selon lui
même parce que les soixante deux ans en
2010 oui bon admettons mais voilà nous
aimons désajustement alors que le
véritable sujet et ça personne ne veut
l'admettre alors qu'en off quand vous
parlez à des responsables ils vous
disent oui effectivement notre système
il n'est pas viable mathématiquement
démographiquement et économiquement
évidemment tout ça n'est pas viable
le véritable la véritable question c'est
comment on passe d'un système
aujourd'hui
budgétairement bancal à un système d'
épargne retraite où les travailleurs et
bien épargnerait pour pouvoir bien
financer leurs vieux jours tout en
permettant aussi de finances et
d'économie puisque c'est là aussi
l'intérêt d'un système par
capitalisation
c'est la possibilité d'épargner et
d'investir davantage dans la partie
palais malgré vos souhaits
alors juste un poids aussi candidat
valentin sur le timing parce qu'on avait
dit normalement ça devait être présentée
au printemps cette réforme là on est
plutôt sur un calendrier postes
européennes
là il ya du effectivement des
préoccupations politiques qui se mêlent
évidemment alors juste un point déjà sur
l' équilibre financier
je crois que cette retraite n'a pas
vocation à en tout cas ce que présente
aujourd'hui doit fait le voit à gérer
l'équilibré financier du système
donc il nous expliquer l'architecturé
globale mais c'est à somme nulle
notamment il va manquer de l'argent
c'est tout alors pour le moment
précisément parce qu'on ne parle pas
d'équilibré financier des systèmes
c'est aussi pour ça que cette
présentation de cette réforme des
retraites aujourd'hui ne soulève pas
particulièrement de débat et qu'elle est
plutôt bien accueillie par les syndicats
mais il ya quand même je reviens à ma
question une anticipation de possible
que ça coince puisqu'on dit ça pas fait
il s'attend au 10 plaisir de me
contredire
bachir malaisie non ça non parce que la
concertation les programmer jusqu'à en
avril mais les européennes c'est en juin
et que pour l'instant le projet de loi
il est toujours prévu d'être présenté au
mois de mai ou juin donc avant les
européennes et cela dit quand bien même
on passerait le cap des européennes pour
présenter projet wacs est ce qui est
après il ici palais municipal autrement
plus compliqué pour amener le maquereau
que les européennes et alors on peut se
dire à la limite ils auraient tout
intérêt à le faire avant les européennes
dont on sait toutefois son rival thomas
s'en prendre plein la tête
oui mais comme hautaine en france comme
disait l'autre il ya toujours une
élection donc on ne fait rien si en
somme si on se vend se réfère vous ne
croyez pas la version en tout cas sauf
les européens tout cas je ne pense pas
mais je peux me tromper je n'ai pas la
science infuse
je ne pense pas que et n'en déplaise aux
journalistes politiques que le que
l'échéancier des élections européennes
soit un critère de choix pour emmanuel
macron pour faire une réforme on l'a vu
depuis un an il a plutôt tendance à
mettre les pieds dans le plat et aller
là où il a pas on n'a pas forcément
envie qu'ils aillent et il fait ce qu'il
dit après on peut juger à tort ou à
raison qu'ils gagnent
on n'a pas tout à fait la canadian vous
attendent et puis après on passe à notre
sujet mais vous répondez lui sur le côté
m l'ailé qu'il a je pense que c'est
encore très timide mais bon ça je pense
qu'on est tous d'accord autour de cette
table pour dire qu'il faudrait une
question c'est comment est ce qu'on peut
avoir un physique un système qui est
déséquilibré alors que la richesse
nationale augmente plus vite que la
démographie
justement on est plus riche qui a 30 ans
et pourtant visiblement on ne doit pas
payer s'accroît de quatre étés sont
beaucoup beaucoup seppuku riche qui a 30
ans il ya trente ans il ya des trois
millions de personnes qui étaient au ps
aujourd'hui on a moins de 500 milles
aujourd'hui le niveau de vie dans le
niveau de vie des retraités de tous les
super héros les actifs qui n'était
jamais arrivé dans l'histoire économique
du pays oui mais voilà la question de
l'augmentation de la richesse globale
qui a accaparé par asada par un petit
nombre à elles progressé crise et
retraités ils ont depuis septembre là on
passe au sujet suivant si vous voulez
bien alors s'il s'agit de l'interdiction
de la burqa
la vie que s'apprête à rendre le comité
des droits de l'homme de l'onu sur la
burqa va faire parler
selon nos confrères de la croix en effet
ce comité estime que la loi de 2010 qui
donc interdit la burqa en france portent
atteinte je cite à la liberté religieuse
ecr et la discrimination
ce même comité de l'onu avait déjà
reproché à la france le renvoi d'une
salariée de la crèche baby loup vous en
souvenez peut-être alors certes le
comité n'a pas de pouvoir coercitif mais
quand même
caroline valentin que peut faire la
france à ce sujet tapé du poing sur la
table et quitter le comité de l'onu ou
tendre la joue gauche écoutez le
problème c'est que peut faire la france
que veut faire la france plus tôt je
vous rappelle que bertrand louvel
président de la cour de cassation dans
son discours du 3 septembre avait
indiqué qu'il allait
rendre bien en compte la décision du ce
comité des droits de l'homme concernant
la jurisprudence baby loup ce qui
n'était pas obligé de fermer ce qu'il a
souhaité faire et ce qu'il ne cesse de
répéter partout dans tous les dîners en
ville dans lequel il va qu'il souhaite
faire ce à quoi on assiste aujourd'hui
c'est une véritable de soumission de la
france une soumission une vraie
soumission mais depuis très longtemps en
fait à une notion des droits de l'homme
qui n'est pas une leçon des droits de
l'homme de la déclaration de 1789 pas du
tout mais une déclaration d une notion
des droits de l'homme qui est une notion
de protection des minorités il maintient
qu'il en est on des sables ça qui est
intéressant dans le cas dans ce cas
présent bien sûr évidemment parce que en
général ces protections toutes ces
règles tout c'est cette nouvelle
conception des droits de l'homme est
instrumentalisée par des associations
qui se battent pour des minorités et une
grande partie de ces quelques payer
parce que bon quand on regarde la
composition des sens non plus mais il ya
effectivement des pays qui peuvent
peut-être blanche et dans le sens
[Musique]
au palais du tau minella de l'inter de
la composition du comité des droits de
l'homme à l'onu
oui il ya un problème on sait depuis
durban est un problème avec l'onu
puisque l'onu c'est c'est tous les pays
du monde et une toute petite partie qui
finance qui sont les pays occidentaux
mais une beaucoup de beaucoup plus de
pays qui qui s'expriment et qui sont des
pays qui ont des des civils bout d'un
moment il faudra dire qu'ils sont aux
civilisations helmand moins avancés que
nous je suis désolé mais d'un moment
faut faire la part comme dirait
kolakowski du bon grain et l'ivraie de
la civilisation de la barbarie ça c'est
la barbarie voyait ça c'est de la
barbarie
georges et kuzmanovic
ce cet avis qui est pas encore sorti
mais encore une fois donc on bossait à
la teneur en tout cas la croix le disait
ce matin c'est une atteinte
effectivement à nos principes et on
devrait pas du tout me prêter plus
d'attention que ça fort heureusement il
n'y a aucune coercition derrière cet
avis et il va évidemment complètement à
l'encontre de tous les principes
républicains et laïcs de notre pays bon
membre de ce comité
je sais plus ils sont six sont la tête
de ce comité mais il ya longtemps
l'arabie saoudite est extrêmement cher
pour être reçu comme chanteront la
connaissance des droits de l'homme et
les comités des dragons ces fusils la
nation belge en c1 c'est le cinéma sion
la commission qui était prisée par
l'arabie saoudite qui comme on le sait
est quand même le premier vecteur du
salafisme et dynamisant radical dans le
monde via l'égypte si la mort est à la
hausse on se pince quand même
sérieusement mais non la france est un
pays laïque elle a combattu longuement
les catholiques pour qu' il n'est plus
de place dans l'espace public et qu'il
soit comme tous les autres religieux
qu'ils aient la liberté de conscience et
la liberté de pratiquer moi je comprends
qu'une personne son identité soit
d'abord sa foi quelques soucis ça peut
être un musulman un catholique je lui
fais peu importe mais la république
française n'autorise à pratiquer son
culte sans aucune répression ce que la
france ne fait pas c'est adapter la
république et l'espace public à une
religion spécifique points c'est pas
plus compliqué que ça donc on n'a pas à
recevoir de directives parce qu'à ce
moment là c'est le délire ouvert on peut
avoir un prof qui s'habillait en orange
de chauves et ont une crécelle pourquoi
pas et qui sont lents sans risque non
pas que donc on ne nous autorise pas en
france ça serait bien que l'onu se
rendent en c1 autorise plus à la liberté
religieuse que bien des pays qui font
qu'ils sont membres de ce comité et de
la commission dont il émane on
n'autorise pas c'est le principe
cela étant cette loi qui date de 2010
elle est peu appliquée on le sait parce
que
elle est compliquée à appliquer parce
que je crois je regarde les chiffres il
ya 200 procès verbaux par an qui sont
dressés ce qui paraît assez dérisoire
par rapport au phénomène lui-même une
faute sévère la matière mais voici masse
mais assez étonné donc moi je suis pas
fan de 2,2 toutes les mesures
coercitives même pathologie ribérac et
vous êtes favorable à la loupe non je
pense que ce genre de deux idéologies
rétrogrades doit être combattue par la
société civile par la parole par la loi
et papa la loi voit c'est vraiment
quelque chose auquel je tiens maintenant
investi dans ce comité ou 7 que cette
commission de l'onu je sais plus ce
comics vers le comité voilà je vous je
pense qu'on peut tous se mettent
d'accord sur le fait qu'elle a
aujourd'hui aucune crédibilité
je dis rien à vie peut-être beaucoup
plus d'urgence en matière de droits de
l'homme dans le monde que s'attaquer à
cette loi là il ya des persécutions
peut-être un peu plus grave ici et là
proche orient au venezuela
d'autres pays où les libertés
religieuses sont autrement plus menacées
qui si donc on avait ce ce cartel d'état
n'a aucune légitimité si vous voulez à
prendre position et c'est à cette
tendance à sélectionner la france
particulièrement là où à mon avis la
monnaie vous dirigez beaucoup plus
autoritaire ça pose question quand même
sur l'agenda politique idéologique de
cette institution qui selon moi n'a
encore une fois aucune légitimité
édité à aucune légitimité en même temps
le gr 10 fois le protocole instituant le
comité des droits de l'homme a été
ratifiée par la france
d'accord mais l'onu c'est quand même une
blague parce que je suis désolé c'est
quand même une organisation alors oui
international qu'il veut promouvoir la
paix mais la majorité des états qui
composent cette organisation sont d état
mafieux qui ne respectent pas les droits
de l'homme chez eux
donc voilà ça fait rire d'entendre cette
institution si vous les critiquez les
régimes occidentaux sur une loi qui est
certes critiquable et guy je pense que
ce n'est pas la meilleure manière de
combattre les idéologies comme
l'islamisme radical
mais là encore quand on regarde la
majorité des états qui composent cette
institution que c'est moi je trouve
qu'elle n'a aucune légitimité à prendre
position sur les droits sur ce que tu
sais faire gagner mark
il ya ce qui est pas une forme
d'hypocrisie avoir fait une loi mais à
être peu ferme dans son application sur
ce sujet là comme sur beaucoup d'autres
le plus dur c'est pas bon goût de loi
c'est pas de la faire voter c'est de la
faire appliquer là on a les images à ces
images là sont sont déjà aujourd'hui la
burqa est interdite sur le public ont
alors on a tous vu des examens ce sujet
de prendre le métro d'aller se promener
un peu dans les quartiers nord de paris
voilà il ya d'héliades il ya des
territoires entiers où on voit plus de
gens sous fausse ou burqa que sans burqa
oui c'est le problème c'est le problème
c'est le problème de l'application des
lois mais ceci dit ça n'a absolument
rien à voir avec le comité des droits de
l'homme devenu gèrent ils peuvent dire
ce qu'ils veulent et ce qu'ils sont il
n'empêche que la loi n'est pas appliquée
attention ce n'est pas juste l'onu on
parle du comité des droits de l'homme de
l'onu dont le rôle est d'interpréter ce
pacte qu'on a effectivement ratifié et
il semblerait il semble que les
présidents de la cour de cassation et de
la cour de cassation va s'aligner sur
cette jurisprudence
c'est ça qui va se passer si ça qu'il ya
après j ressemble à repartir dans un
autre contentieux juridiques parce que
la corée du sud et granit européenne
mais l'info de cassation
dans la terre d'asile on a donné raison
in fine et à la direction après tout il
est tout une longue procédure etc
mais ce qui est important d'abord aussi
c'est de se poser des question des
moyens de que l'on n'a pour lutter
contre la propagation de cette idéologie
qui nous attaquent tous en fait qu'est
ce que c'est que la burqa est bien c'est
le symbole du d'islamisme wahhabite et
quand la propagande
la burqa est utilisé par les islamistes
pour visibiliser rendre visible cette
cette religion et pour la propager pour
propager la version la plus fondamentale
de cette religion nous on a une vision
très individuelle des droits depuis
toujours et ce qu'on oublie et on s'en
rappelle manif est malheureusement
puisque l'islamisme commence à gagner du
terrain chez nous c'est que
effectivement une femme a peut-être le
droit de mettre de se vêtir comme il
veut mais si demain toutes les femmes
s'habillent avec une burqa
moi j'aurais du mal à sortir sans burqa
donc le choix individuel de chacune de
ces femmes aient l'impression de saint
yves de fréquences sur les autres femmes
et des mains sauf qu'on n'a jamais
abordé la question de se défendre contre
l'appropriation dynamisme on a aucune
loi qui permet de le faire et même ses
lois la loi sur la burqa ou même la loi
2004 n'ont pas été prises au nom de la
défense de notre culture contre la
propagation grue en habiller sa de la
nécessité de voir l'une aurait h à la
base il alors il ya c'est peut-être un
peu anecdotique mais je voyais des
commentaires sur twitter et autres me
disait ah ben oui d'ailleurs la burqa
c'est sous ce déguisement que ces
balades et redouane faid à creil avant
de répondre elles ont finalement ils
l'ont trouvée non mais c'était un des
arguments de la loi c'est à dire enfin
même le principal c'était de dire c'est
une halle une façon dont on ne peut pas
voir le visage des gens et leur
physionomie générale donc c'est une wii
c'est dommage qu'il n'ait pas pu se
faire référence à l égalité homme femme
aussi mais c'était pas du tout dans les
gens aiment bien savoir ce que pense ce
comité du
de ceux qui hors jeu va donc dans le
nord-est irakiens ont résisté pendant
cinq ans face à des ch qui les ont
bloqués a condamné qui en reprenant bij
qui ont repris ras cas qui ont été armés
en plus efficace les kurdes et les
femmes kurdes puisque 30% de l'armée
kurde est composée de femmes déléguées
et vous savez ce qu'il faisait à chaque
fois qu'il reprenait une ville les
organiser une grande fête populaire où
les femmes pouvait enlever leur voile et
les brûler en place publique comme un
acte politique de libération de la femme
qui était organisée par les par les
femmes les femmes elles mêmes et ça leur
permettait de rappeler puisque une
partie d'entre eux évidemment souvent
sans musulman et en grande partie des
kurdes de rappeler que rien dans le
coran n'oblige les gens on parle des
syriens qui habitait si l'endroit qui
avaient été les syriens quelles qu aient
obligé de par ce qu'ils y avaient
investi le village
et quand effectivement les canaux
pèlerinage est l'erreur est retirée de
voleurs voilà avec l'obligation que les
femmes auraient dont l'islam où il
allait le voile où on ne parlera pas de
la burqa est une interprétation des plus
juré des wahhabites sur des hadiths
enfin c'est juste une interprétation on
n'a rien à voir avec le coeur de
quelques réactions et commentaires sur
le sujet alors d'abord on vous poser la
question sur twitter selon vous l'onu at
elle raison de remettre en cause
d'interdiction de la burqa en france
sans beaucoup de surprise 83% estimé que
non elle a tort par tout cas ce comité
citoyen payeur nous dit il semble que
les plus grandes puissances ne siège pas
ou plus à ce comité alors je vais pas
redonné la liste mais il ya dix-sept
pays 18 mai mais experts qui sont forme
ce comité et cette juriste issus de pays
européens ya probablement des produits
l'egypte la tunisie
l'afrique du sud l'ouganda la mauritanie
un israélien un japonais de latino
américains un canadien un américain
le pays sont engagés dans une guerre au
yémen ou 5 millions d'enfants sont en
bord de moins de faim franchement
monsieur babineau nous dit la burqa est
un phénomène très minoritaire en france
donc on peut se poser la question de
cette interdiction purement symbolique
on a évoqué la question déjà le
commentaire toujours pourquoi l'onu ne
dit rien dans le cas d'une femme non
voilée dans les pays musulmans
l'interdisant pourquoi l'onu ne dit rien
dans le cas d'une femme non voilée dans
les pays musulmans l'interdisant mais
c'est exactement ça c'est à dire si
l'onu peur du vide et le peu de
crédibilité qui lui reste à peu
continuer effectivement attaqué les
régimes les plus libéraux et ignorer les
des régimes autoritaires
alors ce cette information sur la burqa
ça tombait aussi ce matin avec le sujet
quand même très voisin de
communautarisme à l'école
communautarisme dont jean michel
blanquer a voulu faire un cheval de
bataille la lutte contre le
communautarisme
il a réuni ce matin les correspondants
laïcité dans les académies et on sait
qu'il ya 400 cas d'atteinte à la laïcité
qui ont été relevés ces derniers mois je
crois depuis le mois d'avril ou de mai à
l'école 400 sérieux aux mille au total
on écoute à ce sujet un professeur de
géographie qu en zone d'éducation
prioritaire
iannis roder reid était ce matin sur rtl
nous constatons une chose c'est que la
religion fait partie entièrement partie
de leur vie c'est un socle sur lequel il
s'appuie et qui est structurant pour eux
avec depuis une vingtaine d'années je
trouve moi en tout cas de ce que je vois
sur le terrain une
vision plus rigoristes une pratique plus
stricte par exemple au moment où on
enseigne voltaire par exemple et les
lumières
là on se retrouve avec des élèves qui
n'ont nous conteste pas mais disent leur
désaccord dit non non moi je pense que
non là je ne suis pas d'accord avec ça
carline valentin on le sait tout ça
finalement
on le sait depuis au moins les
territoires perdus de la république qui
a été publié en 2002 et dont personne
n'a parlé c'était voulu
ça a été réédité en 2004 il ya eu ce
fameux rapport obin commenté pas
commandé par le ministère de l'éducation
ministère de l'éducation qui espéraient
que le rapport non écoutés est ce qu'il
ya une prise de conscience il ya blanc
caire l'éducation donc déjà c'est une
mais ce que c'est une forme de prise de
conscience le seul problème c'est que
emmanuel macron nos habitudes en terme
de matière de laïcité ou en même temps
en permanence donc vous avez
effectivement une prise de conscience au
niveau de l'éducation mais vous avez une
progression de la mentalité indigéniste
et parce que les analystes dans la
culture par exemple dans les universités
vous avez quelqu'un comme yassine
belattar qui va être nommé au conseil de
ville et qui ne cesse d'avoir des deux
tweeté alors ils tweetent énormément
yassine belattar donc et tweets toujours
dans le même sens toujours dans le sens
de la protection des minorités de
l'accusation de la mise en question du
racisme des français toujours aubenas
plan là je crois qu'il s'est attaqué un
policier noir qui avait une position
républicaine ce qui n'a pas du tout eu
l'heur de plaire monsieur belattar il
appelait frère j'ai fait demander à
monsieur blatter six mois j'étais sa
soeur c'était formidable qui pensait le
fils unique
oui mais mais
donc il ya c'est toujours le en même
temps on n'est pas rassurés en terme de
laïcité ce qui s'est passé là sur la
burqa sur baby loup ce fameux président
de la cour de cassation qui qui explique
que la jurisprudence de la cour de
cassation et va évoluer en fonction du
comité des droits de l'homme sur sur le
voile ne nous rassure pas mais ce qui
l'est pas plus vous disiez il a fait nos
meilleurs c'est plus flou est ce qu il
pas plus légitime pour le pouvoir public
de d'intervenir sur l'éducation
nationale que en termes de culture où là
on est sur des frontières quand même que
le sait pas il ya quand même une partie
de la culture qui est financé par l'état
donc je vois pas pourquoi l'état
financerait une idéologie qui est contre
elle même en fait parce que finalement
l'idéologie parce que les initialis
multiculturaliste islamistes elle est
contre les principes mêmes de la
république ou pourquoi est ce que notre
argent du citoyen républicain irait
financer des spectacles des programmes
de radio des fines qui vente signés au
dos logique qui est contraire à nos
principes de liberté égalité fraternité
à toute notre identité culturelle
quand vous avez david bobée qui est
directeur du cdn de rouen c'est un
fonctionnaire payé par l'état civil cdn
ce centre dramatique national pour cette
dramatique national d'euros ils essaient
d'un fonctionnaire payé par l'état et il
fait également partie du mouvement des
colonisés les arts qui est un mouvement
de des colonies est distinct qui est
proche d'idéologie de houria bouteldja
et c'est dur c'est quand même fou et que
ce ce david bobée produit une pièce de
théâtre sur moi mais n'ira qui présente
mohamed merah comme une victime de notre
société et que cette pièce de théâtre va
d'ailleurs être de montrer un public
scolaire parce que les cd r on a
vocation à la moi je me pose des
questions
une réaction autour de cette table à cet
accord avec la loi de la république est
là et cités doivent s'appliquer sur dans
les parties de la ligue française sans
aucune exception la france l'est
tous les citoyens encore une fois toutes
les situations à tous les citoyens qui
sont tous les gens qui sont en france
ont la chance de pratiquer leur religion
comme ils le veulent si c'est absolument
impératif pour le de l'appliquer de
manière extrême
ils peuvent aller dans des monastères
com com comme font certains mais pas
dans l'espace public qui encore une fois
doit rester laïque
point barre ce sera le mot de la fin sur
ce sujet on passe maintenant au couple
exécutif alors pas une feuille de papier
à cigarette c'est le premier ministre
qui l'assurent entre lui et le président
macron on les coûts' était hier à
l'assemblée nationale
et pour conclure je voudrais vous dire
allez créer le plus grand calme et la
plus grande sérénité que ni vous
monsieur le député ni aucun commentateur
ni personne jamais ne mettra le début du
commencement de la moitié d'une feuille
de papier à cigarette entre le président
de la république et le premier ministre
alors notre sondage hoxha qui paraît
demain dans le figaro apportera
peut-être une once de jalousie au sein
du couple exécutif parce qu'on va le
voir il ya des différences assez marquée
entre le président de la république et
son premier ministre en terme de
commandes les perçoivent les français on
voit sur le plan de
la confiance est ce que alors attendez
vous voyez c'est ça qu'est ce qui est
affiché la wii edouard philippe l'un
porte sur le terme est un peu confiance
de proche des gens et de plus compétent
en terme en revanche de d'autorité de
charisme et de stature d'homme d'état
c'est emmanuel macron qui est
privilégiée est alors sur ce plan
d'abord est-ce qu'il faut croire à cette
absence de feuille de cigarette marque
si vous avez encore un peu de voix il me
reste encore un petit peu d'accord c'est
vendeur
moi je ne suis pas dans l'est je suis
pas dit dans les coulisses de l'elysée
de nos églises de matignon il y en a
peut-être un cas plus d'autorité via un
partage des rôles entre les deux seins
sur la scène nationale
ah non ça ne me surprend pas puis je
vous dire franchement la limite je veux
dire ce qui se dégage c'est que sur la
compétence notamment bien qu'après
ministre et président de république
c'est normal même rôle c'est normal ils
ont pas la même fonction sont pas les
mêmes attributs vis-à-vis des français
ils sont pas connu la même façon henin
qui a été hué pas l'autre mais ce que
edouard philippe ne prend pas pour
employer un terme un peu qu'elle voulait
plus la lumière en ce moment qu emmanuel
macron ce qui peut être un peu les
manuels après la francophonie donc on
est un peu dans un peu dans l'ombre
parce qu'on finit tout le monde s'en
fout alors que une question française
voilà dix retraite
karl valentin haskell et douars philip
francine la lumière moi j'ai trouvé que
depuis le début du
depuis mai 2007 il est tellement pris la
lumière c'est edouard philippe
il me semble très collaborateurs
d'emmanuel macron et c'est surtout des
manuels makrout on parle c'est lui
jupiter c'est lui qui assoit son
autorité voilà maintenant savoir s'il
n'y a pas une feuille de papier à
cigarette entre les deux très
sincèrement pour moi c'est pas très
intéressant en fait ça le problème c'est
pas cessé on parle du problème des
français là on est en train de résoudre
un problème politique
shiren voit la descente en plus bas il
changera premier ministre basta 7 cette
séquence du remaniement qui tarde pour
est ce que finalement ça ça montre
quelque chose de ce couple exécutif où
c'est pour spéculation on a dit
notamment que edouard philippe voulait
pousser les pions de
m nommé des ministres de droite enfin
venu de la droite essaie de pousser son
avantage
là ça veut dire quelque chose en
politique d'accord je pense qu'on
devrait sans pas s'y intéresser c'est de
la poudre aux yeux
parce que les exploitants de faire cela
cache c'est le délitement complète ce
gouvernement ça fait un an qu'il est au
pouvoir et il est déjà en état de
délitement
intéressant non ce qui est intéressant
c'est de savoir si à ses amis la police
y ont fait de papier ou une porte de
port de plaisance 2 c'est un problème
c'est le délitement actuelle du
gouvernement et l'état de faiblesse de
macron on a une démission à la radio de
du lot le côlon qui qui qui en fait de
même maintenant c'est même le cas stan
un bon petit soldat qui est toujours
derrière qui menace je ne sais pas quoi
parce que je sais pas beaucoup et peut
menacer mais s'il n'est pas ministre de
l'intérieur mais c'est passé pas jupiter
c'est dagobert ça a toujours été comme
ça c'est plus du pcc a non là on est là
on est là on est dans un état de
faiblesse un prénom mais en fait dans la
réalité dans un état de faiblesse du
président qui est absolument totale
et tout cela est dû à ce qui s'est passé
cet été conquis nombreux sont ceux à
l'exécutif qui ont sans ses deux gosses
qui ont essayé de camoufler ses
d'affaires pénales à la sphère benalla
est une affaire d'état collomb s'est
retrouvé dans une situation où il n'a
pas pu exercer son autorité sur sur
l'administration policière qui elle même
s'est vu accuser de
de faire c'est qu'elle faisait alors que
ce sont des haut fonctionnaires sont pas
ce ne sont pas des politiques c'est de
politique donc colons qui était censé
prendre la charge
on a demandé on lui a demandé de se
taire encore une fois ça montre l'état
grave du pouvoir actuel au sommet de
l'état alors affaire d'état benalla
c'est le début de la fin ou au contraire
so what verga nadia moi j'avoue aussi
que ces essais sans succès jusqu'à
maintenant
non mais sérieux s'essayer à l'égout
effectivement moi m'inspire pas pas
beaucoup de choses puisque je suis pas
informé de ce qui s'est dit entre
emmanuel macron et et edouard philippe
excusez moi je veux edouard philippe non
mais c'est pas vraiment ce qui
m'intéresse moi ce qui m'intéresse et
l'envoie l'efficacité gouvernementale et
est ce que c'est une question de
personne
est-ce que ce remaniement va aboutir un
changement à une révolution dans la
manière de fonctionner de fin 2-2 ce
gouvernement je ne pense pas que ce soir
non pas la haine
je pense que ça va changer la vie des
français donc c'est vrai que je
m'interroge parfois sur sur le sur le
temps qu'on passe sur le fait de
commenter ce seront mènera qu'à quelque
chose que je peux vous raconter une
anecdote à une anecdote du vécu mais on
est toujours friand d'années il ya dix
ans j'ai un journaliste politique
éminent confrère que j'apprécie beaucoup
mais dont je tairai le nom par honnêteté
intellectuelle bien voir qui me dit dont
nicolas sarkozy président république
veut faire veut remanier son
gouvernement et y intégrer des
syndicalistes
est-ce que tu connaîtrais pas des gens
qui par hasard pour elle serait ex arrco
compatible vous allez entrer au
gouvernement jeudi d' écoute on affiche
tombe bien il ya intel intel intel je
vais leur passer quelques coups de fil
et puis on voit ça
le lendemain jour le journal je ne sais
plus je ne citerai pas loin du journal
par des intellectuels non plus et qu'est
ce que je vois les noms j'avais cité
dans les sphères autorisée on dit que
pourrait encore gouvernement donc jouer
moi je vous rappelle que lundi on disait
qu'il devait démissionner c'est
éliminant ondées allait être une
démission
complètement il ya un principe de base
maintenant je suis pas très vieux mais
un petit peu quand même depuis toutes
ces années
ceux qui savent ne parlent pas et ceux
qui parlent et ceux qui ne savent pas je
rectifie quand même je vous demandais
pas de pronostics sur le futur
gouvernement sur des affichages de 10
est juste et ce qui est symbolique de
quelque chose sur l'entente entre la
schola en tous cas presque la même
parce que la musique je ne vous donne la
parole parce que je donne juste quelques
réactions frost monsieur babineau
toujours françois hollande a bien raison
on devrait supprimer ce poste de premier
ministre qui est pour le coup obsolète
c'est vrai que françois hollande à
plusieurs reprises récemment s'est
prononcé dans la réflexion sur les
institutions et la vème république pour
la suppression du premier ministre
citoyen payeur edouard fini ce n'est en
fait que le directeur général des
services de monsieur macron il
appréciera sans doute la france la
constitution française est une inconnue
de parlementaires imaginons qu'il y ait
une nouvelle élection législative pour
une raison ou une autre et qu'une autre
majorité n'importe qui dirigera le
gouvernement s'il a supplié président
bah oui mais le président n'a pas de la
majorité dont françois hollande
comment ils devraient continuer à écrire
c'est vraiment où ses mémoires
alors oui justement mais il a besoin pas
très bien compris le sens de la fonction
non pas quelques minutes de l'alcool si
vous voulez bien et de la prévention
dans une lettre ouverte plusieurs
médecins ont effectivement demandé à la
mise de la santé de taxer plus fortement
l'alcool
une augmentation qui devrait selon eux
être destinée à financer la prévention
contre les addictions alors agnès buzyn
qui elle-même alerte d'ailleurs souvent
sur les dangers de l'alcool at-elle
pourtant perdu face au lobby des
alcooliers ou faut-il employés cette
phrase célèbre arrêtons d'emmerder les
français je vous pose la question
george's kuzmanovic bon franchement faut
un peu arrêter et bien la production de
vin est une chose importante en france
il faudrait arrêter de l'attaqué comment
arrêter d'emmerder les français
maintenant évidemment des gens ont des
addictions des gens souffrent de
l'alcoolisme
il faudrait que les services de santé en
général dans ce pays soit plus financer
donc on arrête là aussi de suivre les
directives de l'union européenne qui
demande tout un tas de quotas au vin et
qui refuse que l'on finance les services
publics en particulier l'hôpital
alors marc landré effectivement financer
le coût des addictions c'est ça le
propos était de dire ça et puis plus
largement c'est est ce que le vin est
nocif pour la santé ou pas addictions ou
pas d'addiction
il faut savoir qu'en france il y a si on
prend le tabac sur l'appel à la cause et
qui si on prend part et aussi la
malbouffe
c'est quelque 2,5 millions de personnes
qui sont concernées par ces addictions
là où pour sa part c'est toxicité là ça
coûte 16 milliards et demi à la sécu par
an alors on peut après on peut dire que
c'est un grand débat
oui et puis on va et puis on va et puis
paris deauville le l'alcool provoque
énormément de maladies cardio neuro
vasculaire qui est la deuxième cause de
mortalité en france avec une forte
augmentation des avc chez les femmes on
peut se dire ça vous paraîtrait normal
d'aller demander si on taxe le tabac si
on surtaxe au tabac en france
oui c'est normal de taxer l'alcool et où
est ce que je pourrais pas votre
question est ce que vous gagnez et
lobbys ça fait 50 ans qu'ils gagnent
rappelez-vous de coluche avec son sketch
gérard que tu fumes gérard dué à kitsch
non mais moi je bois du pinard je suis
un patriote mehdi 40 ans en france on
est un pays patriotique qui préféreront
l'alcool qui préféreront le pinard qui
préféreront boire du pinard parce que
c'est pas interdit à taxer les les
drogues ou à lutter contre les maladies
qui sont induites par ces deux réponses
sa rescousse un apn jamais un peu parce
que les a pas de rapports qu'il faut se
rappelle joël de l'état rappelle blessé
par balles aux avocats vers page vous
même si on surtaxe ben oui voilà vous
avez voiture ça dépend quand je vois par
contre non moi je trouve ça facile dans
cette ce paternalisme
non mais
il faut arrêter c'est parce que les
choses sont sont dangereuses nuisibles
qu'il faut tout normes et tout encadrer
les gens s'ils se mettent s'ils sont
conscients que boire de l'alcool
effectivement c'est mauvais pour la
santé et qu'ils font ce choix en
connaissance de cause je vois pas
pourquoi on irait en effet les emmerder
pour reprendre ce que vous avez dit tout
à l'heure et je déteste cette rhétorique
les lobbyistes ont gagné comme s'il y
avait d'un côté les lobbystes et pas de
lobby il ya bien évidemment des intérêts
des deux côtés effectivement il dire
d'être un lobby de l'alcool qui est
intéressant on ne taxe pas trop le
produit mais ce fonds de prévention à la
diction est libre a aussi bénéficié à
certaines catégories professionnelles
qui a intérêt à ce qu'ils soient
alimentés pour pour aussi accroître ses
revenus donc ça veut dire dans ce cas la
contacte pas le tabac passent plus le
dos les gens sont libres de stu est on
avec des cancers du poumon ça veut dire
dans ce cas là compte taxes qu'il n'ya
pas de fiscalité écolo mais est ce que
l'interdiction c'est pas grave et les
gens à interdire et dans un mouchoir non
mais la pollution c'est avoir une telle
histoire parce qu'effectivement la sas à
sa porte atteinte à l'intégrité physique
d'autrui mais comme je bois de l'alcool
ça ne concerne que moi ça ne vous
concerne pas donc mauvais et ne fait pas
comme la cigarette
voilà les furent vous allez bientôt
taxer dessus et puis une c'est celle
qu'a déjà le cas les boissons sucrées
sont taxées elles sont surtaxés tout le
temps en fait vous infantiliser
complètement les gens en fait en
l'occurrence c'est que tout ça c'est des
bébés jusqu'à vous dites 16 milliards ça
coûte 16 milliards à la communauté mais
enfin c'est ça la solidarité et je suis
désolé s'est appuyé pour des gens voilà
pourquoi parce que je suis citoyen je
vote donc on me demande mon avis donc
quand on me demande en offshore mais la
république en personne c'est dommage
mais c'est parce que ça prouve aussi que
la logique de l'étatisation la sécurité
sociale abouti mécaniquement à une
démarche autoritaire puisque forcément
vu qu'on mutualisent les risques de tout
le monde est bien certain comme monsieur
je ne vois pas qui bavent à l'alcool
s'autorise à régenter la vie
d autres alors qu on s attend à voir des
taxes sur l'alcool et sur le tabac et un
moment où vous les mêmes interdirait les
bougies les boules les bougies odorantes
chez soi je dire cette réputation native
est insupportable la présentation de la
rb6 faut taxer réglementés c'est plus
les gens qui ont un surpoids par exemple
vous savez que c'est cancérigène d'avoir
un peu de surpoids ce qu'ils font pas de
nos morts ils devraient payer plus
d'impôts ceci dit abbas advienne tout
juste quelques réactions d'abord vous
êtes alors la question twitter pensez
vous que le poids de leur lobby de
l'alcool est trop important en france
oui à 56% qu'un wci l'alcool n'est pas
bon il faut l'interdire
là encore on veut mettre une taxe points
de suspension et j'en ai à être des
responsables maskargo nato peut-être
faudrait-il arrêté d'infantiliser les
gens assure votre joli et ça ne sert
qu'à faire des recettes pour l'état si
beaucoup à tous les quatre merci aussi à
gérer mais ponthieu qui nous du figaro
médias réseaux sociaux qui nous a relayé
toutes vos questions et vous retrouver
guillaume roquette demain pour un
nouveau point de vue
[Musique]